five nights of Freddy's known for its
many secrets here are the top five
secrets you definitely haven't heard of
before
number one finites of Freddy's is going
to be a trilogy of games we know the
third one is coming but do you know when
1987 is an important number in the five
nights at Freddy's universe the bite of
87 that started it all the first game
was released on Steam August 18 the
second game 10th of November that's 87
days apart assuming the next one follows
the same pattern which isn't
unreasonable All Things Considered the
third game will be released on the 5th
of February number two according to
recently released statistics of the
steam platform
studies show that approximately 75
percent of the people who owned the game
haven't actually played it this is
largely believed due to the majority of
them being a bunch of [ __ ] number 3
mangle an animatronic from the second
game but what does she really say beyond
a static did you hear that this played
back again slower and decrypted
who assists no men and what is he one
leave your theory in the comments number
four there's a deleted easter egg in the
game that can still be accessed by
entering - dev mode in the launch code
after beating the game creating a custom
night with Freddy Bonnie chica and foxy
with the following number sequence one
three three seven most likely deleted
due to copyright laws this hidden code
unlocks MLG mode in the game it doesn't
change much but now you can quickscope
Freddy
number five who are you in this game and
how come you never move from your
station no matter what happens or you
perhaps tied down to your post
no but there's one clue hidden when
beating the game you are presented with
a paycheck of one hundred and twenty
dollars that counts to four dollars per
hour which means you're probably a
Mexican it's in Freddy's eyes that we
find the final piece of the puzzle by
zooming in close enough we can see in
the reflection a silhouette but what is
it could it be the player of the game is
Mexican Steven Hawkins this explains the
players inability to move and acceptance
of low paycheck but wait what if Steven
Hawkins is really an animatronic it
makes so much sense it almost hurts just
listen to him speak I am Steven Hawkins
I'm not an animatronic wait did you see
that closer closer
do you see oh boy that sure was scary
please forgive the jump-scare all right
if you liked this video go ahead and
leave a like I really appreciate it i
want to thank my buddy ken cinnamon
toast ken for helping me out with this
video the first fact might actually be
true we discovered it by accident and I
think it'd be hilarious if it turned out
to be correct the Mexican joke was Ken's
as well as if you have a problem with it
go ahead and check out his channel and
tell him all about it until the next
episode keep looking out for the brofist
hey Steven how are you even what are you
doing in here